et puis l'armée russe a bombardé ce
lundi pour la première fois les
faubourgs d'odessa port de la mer noire
située dans le sud ouest de l'ukraine
des immeubles d'habitations ont été
détruits mais il n'y a pas de victime
selon les autorités municipales sur le
front diplomatique à présent à bruxelles
où les européens sont réunis en ce
moment pour examiner de nouvelles
sanctions contre moscou le chef de la
diplomatie européenne a dénoncé tout à
l'heure un crime de guerre des russes à
marioupol on écoute josep borrell
rachel reid la russie comme est vraiment
beaucoup de crimes de guerre c'est le
mot nous devons le prononcer ce qui se
passe à marioupol est un crime de guerre
massif les bombes détruit ce tournoi
tout le monde l'est de manière aveugle
et bordé et narines des skins lunettes
et mana c'est quelque chose d'horrible
que nous devons condamner dans les
termes
de la ville sera complètement détruites
et les gens sont en train de mourir un
trail
et à bruxelles on retrouve tout de suite
pierre bénazet notre correspondant
pierre bonjour les européens sont donc
réunis en ce moment pour discuter d'un
cinquième train de sanctions contre
moscou il étudie notamment un embargo
sur le pétrole russe mais déjà la russie
les a mis en garde oui effectivement la
russie qui affirme et assène que des
sanctions contre les hydrocarbures
russes coûterait extrêmement cher à
l'europe les et la russie essayait
évidemment d'enfoncer un coin dans
l'actuelle unité transatlantique entre
les etats unis qui ont déjà décrété un
tel embargo et le canada aussi la russie
affirmant que ça ne coûte rien aux états
unis de prendre une telle décision
puisqu'il ne sont pas dépendantes des
états des hydrocarbures russes comme le
sont les européens bref le jeu
diplomatique bat son plein ce qui est
certain c'est que au sein même de
l'union européenne
la question n'est plus taboue on avait
dit à nouveau lors du sommet de
versailles que de nouvelles sanctions
massives pourraient être prises c'est
actuellement en discussion le ministre
irlandais ce matin en arrivant indique
qu'il était hors de question de ne pas
en parler le premier le ministre belge
lieu le ministre lituanien pardon des
affaires étrangères estime qu'il faut
désormais déclencher cet embargo tous
les pays baltes et les pays bas 1 semble
plutôt sur cette ligne là il ya encore
ceci dit des débats en particulier avec
l'allemagne qui estime que le coût
serait vraiment trop important pour les
européens pour l'allemagne mais aussi
pour les autres européens l'allemagne
n'est pas le seul à penser que ce coût
est extrêmement important pour
l'économie européenne
bref les discussions vont bon train et
on a entendu par exemple la ministre
allemand des affaires étrangères ce
matin annales annabelle boc a affirmé
qu'il fallait par exemple instaurer un
pont aérien avec l'ukraine qu'il fallait
de nouvelles sanctions at personam la
liste des entités et des personnes
touchées par les sorties européennes
devaient être étendues à tous les 27
semble d'accord là dessus en revanche
elle n'a à aucun moment parlé d'un
embargo sur le charbon le pétrole que
réclame d'autres pays bruxelles où joe
biden le président américain est attendu
cette semaine il ira ensuite en pologne
vendredi oui effectivement joe biden
arrive donc à bruxelles jeudi jour où se
tenait aussi où se tient aussi un sommet
européen ce qui a décrété ce qui a
évidemment déclenché l'agenda de l'otan
pour installer convoquer ce sommet
extraordinaire de l'otan pour parler de
l'ukraine joe biden doit parler cet
après midi avec emmanuel macron boris
johnson mario draghi entre autres et
olaf scholz aussi et ils vont essayer de
rassembler leurs positions d'afficher
encore plus d'unités avant ce sommet de
l'otan où il sera question évidemment
peut-être du partage du fardeau sur les
dépenses militaires extraordinaire que
les états unis ont déclenché en envoyant
des centaines des milliers d'hommes en
renfort dans les pays d'europe orientale
face à l'ukraine les européens qui de
leur côté aujourd'hui vont commencer à
adopter leur futur boussole stratégique
pour préparer leur réponse face aux
défis du monde à venir et en particulier
de la russie il devrait partir en est
spécifiquement déclencher une force de
réaction rapide de 5000 hommes une
vieille promesse bref les européens se
mettent aussi en ordre de bataille et
toutes ses positions vont être discutés
évidemment lors du sommet de l'otan
jeudi avant cette visite de joe biden en
pologne pour faire face pourrait y
virent envisager les mesures de soutien
l'ukraine et comment l'europe doit se
préparer à faire face à la russie à
terme merci beaucoup pierre bénazet 2